hi there Steve Kaufman here today and I
want to talk about what makes an ideal
language teacher and I'm going to talk
about that for a couple of reasons it
has to do with the things that I'm
experiencing in learning Arabic and it's
also in response to an article that I
saw via Twitter about language
instruction I would like to say first of
all that we've had some response from
people willing to help out with our mini
stories project translating and
recording and so and we had one person
who volunteered to do Swedish stories
for us and another in Danish so I very
much appreciate that in both cases the
question comes up of regional column
accents so in southern Sweden for
example they pronounce the are in a
guttural way is that you know an
obstacle for beginner learners I have no
idea this is something you're gonna have
to deal with also when it comes to you
know accents and stuff and the different
dialects I am working on modern Standard
Arabic myself I would like to get other
versions of the many stories in Egyptian
Arabic and possibly Levantine Arabic so
I looked up Levantine Arabic and it
appears that that's not a you know you
know a unified concept either that in
Lebanon they speak differently from
Syria from Jordan from Palestine so I'm
not sure what to do there but if there
are people out there who are willing to
translate our modern Standard Arabic
lessons into regional variations and
record them for us and if the sound
quality is good then I would be very
interested in hearing from you and even
languages like Catalan or Thai or if
anybody wants to volunteer and prepare
to give a year free use of link
assuming that the accent the quality and
so forth is of a high quality
right so that's a bit of a digression
now or even we had a request for camel
again if someone can provide that in
Tamil we can also put Tamil up now on
this question of what makes a good
language teacher alright the best
language teacher I ever had was the
professor I had at McGill University who
essentially tremendously motivated me to
learn French and after French I
subsequently learned other languages so
he had a major impact on my life not by
teaching me the rules of French grammar
but by motivating me so I would like to
say up front I think the most important
quality for a good language teacher is
the ability to motivate people
overwhelmingly that's the most important
thing because what's the person's
motivated he'll put in the time okay
and if he's motivated he will pay
attention to the language so if you
remember the three keys to language
learning were your attitude your
willingness to put in the time or the
time that you spend and your ability to
notice but the ability to notice is
almost almost something that comes
naturally if you're motivated if you
spend time with the language you will
start to notice things and so therefore
that's the most important element now
this article that I was going to refer
to it talked about the sort of cults
itself and I'm gonna put a link to this
but it says cutting the Gordian knot of
language curriculum structural syllabus
as a checklist okay again it's one of
these very learned and how academic
thing here you know articles but it
basically presents the arguments of a
certain rod Ellis who is very well known
in the ELT you know English language
teaching world versus another gentleman
whose name is Brahm fit and so the idea
is you know traditionally languages
English are taught and there's a
syllabus and these are the grammar
points that the teacher has to cover in
this order and this is how you teach it
and
you test your students on and according
to Brahm fit then he has a graph as
you'll see in this article and in the
first year emphasis should
overwhelmingly be on accuracy whereas by
the fifth year the emphasis is
overwhelmingly on fluency all right
Ellis has a different perspective and
there's a you can drill in this article
I thought I'll put both links up there
one to this article then to the Ellis
article and he says no you should be you
can't introduce the grammar at it first
of all there is no natural order for
learning grammar a second of all if you
introduce grammar too early the students
aren't yet ready for it which is
absolutely true and then he says
therefore we should have a whole bunch
of activities and tasks in the classroom
and then gradually focus more and more
on accuracy which as a general concept I
agree with however getting back then -
so that's the debate and also Ellis in
his article presents some information
from a very interesting survey that he
made of teachers and the gist of it is
that lip service is paid to the idea of
call it a communicative a pol approach
or a content-based approach to language
learning whereas the majority of
teachers feel that we should concentrate
on grammar and they give reasons such as
either they say that it's necessary
despite all the language acquisition
research by stephen krashen and others
people don't believe the research and
they think that the students expected
which may be true but isn't always true
and so that there's this tremendous
dichotomy between some sense of a
appreciation of the fact that language
learning is generally is a gradual
process of absorbing a language through
lots of activity and it might be
primarily listening it
the research says that but the teachers
still want to teach grammar another
reason I think they like to teach
grammar is because it's something
concrete that they can teach so I get
back now to my Arabic I have started
with Arabic reading on my iPad reading
euronews in Arabic okay now in order
using link now in order for me to make
sense of your own use and it comes with
audio and text I am looking up every
second word more than every second word
but I am being exposed to the language
and it is interesting content and I very
that this morning while doing the dishes
I was listening to one of my earlier
lessons and I just noticed more and more
stuff now I noticed for example that if
that's you know they did something it
ends up in oon at the end of the verb
and all kinds of little stuff like that
which I had been exposed to before and
forgotten and that problem with grammar
instruction is you forget it right away
so I feel if I wanted the ideal grammar
the ideal teacher for me okay first of
all it doesn't have to be a native
speaker native speaker has many
advantages very often the native speaker
is more motivating because you want to
communicate with a native speaker in the
language however you can have a teacher
and someone you talk to and the person
you talk to and you converse with that
has to be a native speaker in my opinion
already that's it's best if it's a
native speaker I find that more
motivating you can also talk to
non-native speakers but I prefer the
native speaker however if I had a
teacher now here's my dispute from the
ideal teacher for me say in Arabic is
someone who could go out and find me
material graded because this urine uses
just a little too difficult matter
little a lot too difficult for
and now after four months I'm tired of
my mini stories
I still do them because I pick up stuff
every time but it's no longer fresh so I
would like to have something that's
fresh and yet interesting
I don't want children stories I don't
find that interesting at all but
something about the history of certain
country or whatever in somewhat
simplified language sort of graded I had
this when I was learning Chinese for
example does that exist can someone find
it or even you know I bought some I
bought some books on learning Arabic for
example this Manu habla de but there's
no digital text so I actually fold them
this morning and I said do you have
digital text that I could use in length
and they said no we don't why don't you
first of all don't believe them I think
maybe they didn't understand me I said
the texture digital I should have maybe
said the text electronic or something
said no no but the text knew me as a and
I might contact them again however the
best teacher is someone therefore who
motivates you who encourages you to do a
lot of stuff on your own I don't think
it's necessary to have activities where
we force people to use the language I
certainly don't think it's necessary to
have a syllabus or a curriculum of
grammar points that have to be ticked
off in fact this graph that was in this
article where year one is mostly
accuracy year five is mostly fluency I
would stand it on his head you know
initially it's just get it in you listen
to it read it words you know kids in a
classroom could be encouraged just like
I was doing save a bunch of words see
the number go up okay 10 20 30 every
time you say 25 words bingo something
comes on just deal with the language get
it in you you don't need to have grammar
to understand more or less what's in the
tenth as long as a teacher doesn't come
along and ask you what was this and why
was that
forget all that just let people get
exposed to the language watch movies
cartoons read listen get that initial
exposure experience with the language so
a teacher that can guide you help you
find resources of your learning Romanian
where do I find Romanian content where
do I find Romanian grammar and if I have
a question I can ask and that if I have
a question and I ask the answer can be
provided by a non-native speaker if I
want to actually have an online
discussion again teacher should say
here's where you can go on find language
partners native speaking language
partners and maybe you'd have to pay for
that but at least it provides you with
some sense of what you can do and how
you can learn to me a language teacher
is a guide is a cheerleader is a coat if
that guy teacher coach also is a native
speaker and can provide that native
interaction so much the better if not
there are other ways of getting that and
in in any case in my view a large part
of the initial period is getting the
language in you and again on this graph
here you know they're talking five years
five years that's a long time look I've
been at arabic for four months and i'm
starting to read this euro news and
listen to it I don't understand it very
well or at all really but in a few
months I will because when I started
four months ago with my many stories I
didn't understand anything so it needn't
take five years if the teacher can
motivate the learner guide to learn nor
show them the way and not worry so much
about instructing the grammar based on a
certain curriculum because once the
learner has had enough exposure to the
language they will then be able to use
even instruction that the teacher
provides in grammar or other sources of
grammar I can find it on the web
Arab grammar I can buy a small book it's
not that big a deal okay so that's again
picking up on my normal themes but
specifically with reference to what
makes a good language teacher
[Music]